‏remember
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله ا اد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيم اعتدلوا استو سو الصف سد
الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قال فما خطبكم ايها
يرسلون قال انا ارسلنا الى قوم
مجرمين لنرسل عليهم حجاره من
طين مسومه عند ربك للمسرفين
فاخرجنا من كان فيها من
المؤمنين فما وجدنا فيها ير غير بيت من
المس
مين وتركنا فيها ايه للذين يخافون العذاب
الاليم وفي موسى اذ ارسلناه الى
فرعون وفي موسى اذ ارسلناه الى فرعون
بسلطان مبين فتولى بركنه وقال ساحر او
مجنون فاخذناه وجنوده
فنبذناهم في
اليم
فبنا وهو
ملي عاد اذ ارسلنا عليهم الريح العقيم ما
من شيء اتت عليه
الا
الاه
ك وفي ثمود اذ قيل لهم تمتعوا حتى حين
فعتوا عن امر
ربهم اخذتهم الصاعقه
وينظرون فما استطاعوا من قيام وما كانوا
منتصرين وقوم نوح من قبل انهم كانوا انهم
كانوا قوم من
فاسقين
والسماء
بنينا
وانا
لموسعون والارض فرشناها فنعم الماهدون
ومن كل شيء خلقنا زوجين لعلكم
تذكرون
ففروا الى الله اني لكم
ير
مبين ولا تجعلوا مع الله الها اخر اني لكم
منه نذير
مبين كذلك ما اتى الذين من قبلهم من رسول
الا
قالوا الا قالوا ساحر او
مجنون اتواصوا
به بل هم قوم
طاغون فتول عنهم فما انت
بملوم وذكر فان الذكرى تنفع
المؤمنين وما خلقت الجن
والانس الا
ليعبد
ما منهم من رزق وما
اريد
ان ان الله هو الرزاق ذو القوه المتين
فان الذين ظلموا ذنوبا مثل ذنوب
اصحابهم فلا
يستعجلون فويل للذين كفروا من يومهم الذي
يوعدون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
وكتاب في رق
منشور
الم والبيت المعمور والبحر المسج والسف
المرفوع والبحر
المسجور
ان عذاب ربك
لواقع يوم تنور
السماء مورا وتسير جبال سيرا
ان عذاب ربك لواقع ما له من
دافع يوم تمور
السماء مورا وتسير الجبال سيرا فويل يومئذ
للمكذبين
الذين هم في
خوض
يلعبون يوم يدعون الى نار
جهنم
دعا هذه النار التي كنتم بها
تكذبون افس هذا ام
انتم لا تبصرون اصلوها فاصبروا او لا
تصبروا
سواء
عليكم انما تج ما كنتم
تعملون ان المتقين في
جنات ونعيم
فاكهين
بما اتاهم ربهم
وقاهم ربهم عذاب
الجحيم
كلوا
هئا بما كنتم
تعملون متكئين على
سرر
مصفوف وزوجناهم
بحور عين والذين امنوا
واتبعتهم
ذريتهم بايمان الحقنا بهم
ذريتهم الحقنا بهم ذريتهم وما
التناهم من عملهم من شيء كل
امرئ بما كسب رهين
وامددناهم
بفاكهه ولحم مما
يشترون فيها كاسا لا لغو فيها ولا
تاثيم ويطوف عليهم غلمان لهم كانهم لؤلؤ
لؤلؤ مك
ويطوف عليهم غلمان لهم
كانهم لؤلؤا مكنون واقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتساءلون قالوا انا كنا قبل في اهلنا
مشفقين
فمن الله علينا ونا عذاب
السوم انا كنا من قبل
ندعوه
انه هو البر
الرحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
ن انت
[Silence]
السلام
‏s
[Silence]
خ
استقيم اعتدل
سو الصف
ان شاء
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
نستعين اهدنا الصرا
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ويطوف عليهم غلمان لهم كانهم لؤلؤ
مكنون
واقبل بعضهم على بعض
يتساءلون قالوا انا كنا قبل في اهلنا
مشفقين فمن الله
علينا فمن الله علينا ووقانا عذاب
السموم انا كنا من قبل ندعوه ان انه هو
البر
الرحيم فذكر
فما نعمه ربك
بكاهن ولا
مجنون ام يقولون شاعر نتربص به ريب المنون
قل
تربصوا قل تربصوا
فاني معكم من
المتربصين
ام تامرهم
احلامهم بهذا ام هم قوم
طاغون ام يقولون تقوه بل لا
يوقنون ام يقولوا ن تقوه بل
لا فلياتوا بحديث مثله ان كانوا
صادقين ام خلقوا من غير شيء ام هم
الخارقون ام السماوات والارض بل لا
يؤمنون ام عندهم
خزائن ربك ام هم
المسيطرون ام لهم سلم يستمعون
فيه فليات
مستمعهم
بسلطان مبين ام له البنات ولكم
البنون ام تسالهم اجرا
فهم من مغرم
مثقلون ام
عندهم الغيب فهم
يكتبون ام يريدون كيدا فالذين كفروا هم
المكيدون ام لهم اله غير الله
سبحان الله عما
يشركون وان يروا كسفا من
السماء ساقطا يقولوا سحاب مركوم فذرهم حتى
يلاقوا يومهم الذي
يوعدون يوم لا يغني عنهم كيدهم شيئا ولا
هم
ينصرون
وان للذين ظلموا عذابا دون ذلك
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون واصبر لحكم ربك فانك
باع وسبح بحمد ربك حين
تقوم ومن الليل
فح وا ادبارا
النجوم
والنجم اذا هوى ما ضل صاحبكم وما غوى وما
ينطق عن الهوى ان هو الا وحي
يوحى علمه شديد القوى ذو
مره
فاستوى وهو بال الافق الاعلى ثم دنى فتدلى
فكان قاب قوسين او ادنى فاوحى الى عبده ما
اوحى ما كذب الفؤاد ما راى افتمارونه
على ما
يرى لقد راه نزله اخرى عند سدره المنت
عندها
جنه
الماوى اذ يغشى السدره ما يغشى ما زاغ
البصر وما طغى لقد راى من ايات ربه
الكبرى
افرايتم اللات والعزى ومناه الثالثه
الاخرى الكم الذكر وله الانثى
تلك
قسمه
ضيزا ان هي
اسماء ان هي الا
اسماء
سميتموها انتم
واباؤكم ما انزل الله بها من
سلطان ان تتبعون الا الظن وما تهوى
الانفس و ان يتبعون الا الظن وما تهوى
الانفس ولقد
جاءهم من ربهم
الهدى ام
للانسان ما
تمنى فلله الاخره والاولى
وكم من ملك في السماوات لا تغني
شفاعتهم شيئا لا تغني شفاعتهم شيئا الا من
بعد ان ياذن الله لمن
يشاء الا من بعد ان ياذن الله لمن
يشاء
ويرضى ان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره
ليسمون
الملائكه تسميه
الانثى وما لهم به من علم ان يتبعون الا
الظن وان
الظن لا يغني من الحق
شيئا فاعرض عمن تولى عن عن ذكرنا ولم يرد
الا الحياه
الدنيا ذلك
مبلغهم من
العلم ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن
سبيله وهو اعلم بمن
اهتدى الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم راط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم و
الضالين
امين ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
ليجزي الذين
اساءوا بما عملوا ويجزي الذين احسنوا
بالحسنى الذين يجتنبون
كبائر الاثم والفواحش الا
اللمم ان ربك واسع
المغفره هو اعلم بكم اذ
انشاكم من الارض واذ انتم
اجنه في بطون
امهاتكم ف نكوا
انفسكم هو اعلم بمن اتقى افرايت الذي تولى
واعطى
قليلا
واكدى
اعنده علم الغيب فهو يرى ام لم ينبا بما
في صحف موسى
وابراهيم الذي
وثا وابرا
الذي وفى الا تزر
وازره وزر اخرى وان ليس
الانسان ما سعى
وان سعيه سوف يرى ثم يجزاه
الجزاء
الاوفى
وان الى ربك
المنتهى وان انه هو اضحك
وابكى
وانه هو امات واحياه
وانه خلق الزوجين الذكر
والانثى من نطفه اذا تمنى
و
عليه نشه الاخرى
وانه هو اغنى واقنى
وانه هو رب
الشعرا
وانه اهلك عادن الاولى وثمود فما ابقى
وقوم نوح من قبل
انهم كانوا هم اظلم
واطغى
والمؤتفكه
اهوى وال فكه اه فغشاها ما غش فباي
الا ربك
تتما هذا نذير من
النذر
الاولى ازفت
الا ليس لها من دون الله
كاشفه اف هذا الحديث
تعجبون
وتضحكون ولا تبكون
وانتم
سامدون فاسجدوا لله
واعبدوا الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اقتربت الساعه
وانشق القمر وان يروا ايه يعرضوا ويقولوا
سحر مستمر وكذبوا واتبعوا
اهواءهم وكل امر
مستقر ولقد
جاءهم من
الانباء ما فيه ازدجر
حكمه
بالغه فما تغني
النذر فتولى عنهم يوم يدعو الداعي الى
شيء خش عن
ابصارهم خشعا
ابصارهم يخرجون من الاجداث كانهم جراد
منتشر مهطعين الى الدار
يقول
الكافرون هذا يوم
عسير الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏se
استقيم واستووا تر
الصوتين
الله
اكبر شريك
له بسم الله بس الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ضالين
امين كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح فكذبوا عبدنا
وقالوا مجنون وازدجر فدعى ربه اني
مغلوب
فانتصر ففتحنا ابواب السماء
بماء
منهمر وفجر الارض
عيونا فالتقى
الماء على امر قد قدر وحملناه على ذات
الواح ودسر تجري باعيننا
جزاء لمن كان كفر ولقد تركناها ايه
فهل من
مدكر فكيف كان عذابي ونذر ولقد يسرنا
القران للذكر فهل من مدكر كذ عاد فكيف كان
عذابي ونذر انا ارسلنا عليهم ريحا صرصرا
في يوم نحس
مستمر تنزع الناس س كان اعجاز نخل
منقعر فكيف كان عذابي ونذر ولقد يسرنا
القران للذكر فهل من
مدكر كذبت ثمود
بالنذر قالوا ابشرا منا واحدا نتبعه انا
اذا لفي ضلال وسعر اقي ذكر عليه من بيننا
بل هو كذاب اشر سيعلمون غدا من الكذاب
الاشر ارسل الناقه فتنه لهم فارتقبهم
واصبر ونبئهم ان
الماء قسمه بينهم كل شب محتضر فنادوا
صاحبهم فتع ف فكيف كان عذابي ونذر انا
ارسلنا عليهم صيحه واحده فكانوا كهشيم
المحتظر
ولقد يسرنا القران للذكر فهل من
مدكر كذبت قوم لوط
بالنذر انا ارسلنا عليهم حاصبا الا الو ط
نجيناهم
بسحر نعمه من عندنا كذلك نجزي من شكر ولقد
انذرهم بطشتنا فتماروا
بالنذر ولقد راودوه عن ضيفه فطمسنا اعينهم
فذوقوا عذابي
ونذر ولقد صبحهم بكره عذاب مستقر فذوقوا
عذابي ونذر ولقد يسرنا القران للذكر فهل
من مدكر ولقد
جاء ال فرعون
النذر كذبوا
باياتنا كلها
فاخذناهم اخذ عزيز
مقتدر اكفاركم خير من
اولئكم ام لكم
براءه في الزبر ام يقولون نحن جميع
منتصر سيهزم الجمع ويولون الدبر بل الساعه
موعدهم والساعه ادى
وامر ان المجرمين في ضلال
وسعر يوم يسحبون في النار على وجوههم
ذوقوا مس سقر انا كل شيء خلقناه بقدر وما
امرنا الا
واحده كلمح بالبصر ولقد اهلكنا اشياعكم
فهل من مدكر فكيف كان عذابي ونذر ولقد
يسرنا القران للذكر فهل من
مدكر
ان ان المجرمين في ضلال وسعر يوم يسحبون
في النار على وجوههم ذوقوا مس سقر انا كل
شيء خلقناه بقدر وما امرنا الا واحده كلمح
بالبصر ولقد اهلكنا اشياعكم فهل من مدكر
وكل شيء فعلوه في الزبر وكل صغير
وكبير مستطر ان المتقين في
جنات ونهر في مقعد صدق عند
ملك
مقتدي الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الرحمن
علم
القران خلق
الانسان علمه
البيان الشمس والقمر
بحسبان والنجم والشجر
يسجدان
والسماء رفعها ووضع الميزان الا تطغوا في
الميزان اقيموا الوزن بالقسط ولا تخسروا
الميزان
والارض وضعها
للا فيها فاكهه
وال
الاكمام والحب ذو العصف
والريحان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان خلق الانسان من صال
كالفار وخلق ال
من
مارج من
نار فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان رب المشرقين ورب
المغربين فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان مرج البحرين
يلتقيان بينهما برزخ لا
يبغيان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يخرج منهما اللؤلؤ
والمرجان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان وله الجواري المنشات في البحر
كالاعلام فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان كل من عليها فان ويبقى وجه ربك ذو
الجلال
والاكرام فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يساله من في السماوات
والارض كل يوم هو في شان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان سنفرغ لكم ايها
الثقلان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يا معشر الجن والانس ان استطعتم ان
تنفذوا من اقطار السماوات والارض فانفذوا
لا
تنفذون الا
بسلطان ف اي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يرسل عليكما شواظ من نار ونحا الاء
ربكما
تكذبان انشقت
السماء فكانت ورده
كالدهان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يعرف مجرمون بسهم فيؤخذ
بالنواصي
والاقدام فباي
بلاء ربكما
تكذبان هذه جهنم التي يكذب بها
المجرمون يطوفون بينها وبين حميم
ان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان
ولمن خاف مقام ربه
جنتان فباي الاء ربكما
تكذبان
دواتى افنان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان فيهما عينان تجريان فباي
تكذبان فيهما من كل فاكهه زوجان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان متكئين على فرش
بطائنها من استبرق وجنى
الجنتين دان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان فيهن قاصرات الطرف لم يطمثهن
انس قبلهم ولا
جان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان
كانهن الياقوت
والمرجان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان هل جزا
الاحسان الا
الاحسان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان
ومن دونهما
جنتان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان
مدهامتان
فباي
الاء
ربكما
تكذبان فيهما عينان نضاختان
فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان فيهما فاكهه ونخل
ورمان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان فيهن خيرات حسان فباي
تكذبان حور
مقصورات في الخيم فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان لم يطمثهن
قبلهم
جان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان متكئين على رفرف خطر وعبقري
حسان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان تبارك اسم ربك ذي الجلال
والاكرام الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحم
الحمدله والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله
وصحبه ومنوه ومن تحان يوم
الد ان شاء
الله
‏people that could
trust
people
[Silence]
عنه
‏difficult
‏you
have
people
just ‏and
that
[Silence]
tak
م
[Silence]
4e
لام
[Silence]
اب
علسلام
سبحان
[Silence]
الله
رول الله صلى عليه
وسلم
عليهه
[Silence]
عليهه ‏well other
people
we and you
can
all
things
[Silence]
الله
سالى
الله اللهبه
وردنا
عليه
[Silence]
الهلامه
عليه
اله الا محمد
رولى علم الهول الله ربنا اتنا في الدن
حسنه وفيره حسنه وقنا ع الننا عقنا ع
النمال
[Silence]
ربنا تقل منك السمي العليم وتب علنا
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
امين
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهد الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
اذا وقعت الواقعه ليس لوقعه كاذبه خافه
رافعه اذا رجت الارض رجا وبست الجبال بسا
فكانت
هباء
منبثا وكنتم ازواجا ثلاثه فاصحاب الميمنه
ما اصحاب
الميمنه اصحاب المشا اصحاب
المشامه السابقون
السابقون
اولئك
المقربون في جنات
النعيم ثله من
الاولين وقليل من
الاخرين على سرر
موضونه متكئين عليها
متقين
يط ولدان
مخلدون باكواب واباريق وكاس من معين لا
يصدعون عنها ولا
ينزفون
وفاكهه مما خيرون ولحم طير مما
يشتهون وحور عين كامثال اللؤلؤ المكن نون
جزاء بما كانوا
يعملون لا يسمعون فيها لغوا ولا
تاثيما الا قيلا سلاما سلاما واصحاب
اليمين ما اصحاب
اليمين في سدر
مخضود وطلح
منضود وظل
ممدود
وماء
مسكوب
وفاكهه كثيره لا
مقطوعه ولا
ممنوعه
وفرش
مرفوعه انا
انشاناهن ان
شاء
جعلنا
ابكارا عربا اترابا لاصحاب اليمين ثله من
الاولين
وثله من
الاخرين واصحاب الشمال ما اصحاب الشمال في
سموم وحميم
وظل يحموم لا بارد ولا كريم انهم كانوا
قبل ذلك مترفي
وكانوا يصرون على الحنث
العظيم وكانوا يقولون ائذا متنا
وك وعظاما اانا
لمبعوثون
اباءنا
الاولون قل ان الاولين
والاخرين
لمجموعون الى ميقات يوم مع
ثم انكم ايها
الضال
المكذبون لاكلون من شجر من زقوم ئون منها
البطون فشاربون عليه من
الحميم فشاربون شرب الهيم هذا نزلهم يوم
الدين
فلولا
تصدقون
افرايتم ما
تنون اانتم
تخلقونه ام نحن
الخالقون نحن قدرنا بينكم الموتى وما نحن
بمسبوقين على ان نبدل امثالكم
وننشئكم فيما لا
تعلمون ولقد علمتم
فلولا
تذكرون
افرايتم ما
تحرثون اانتم تزرعونه ام نحن
الزارعون لو
نشاء لجعلناه حطاما فظلتم
تفكه انا مرمون بل نحن
محرومون افرايتم الماء الذي
تشربون اانتم انزلتموه من المزن ام نحن
المنزلون لو
نشاء جعلناه اجاجا فل لا
تشكرون افرايتم النار التي
تورون
اانتم انشاتم شجرتها ام نحن
المنشئون
نحن جعلناها تذكره ومتاعا
للمقوين فسبح باسم ربك
العظيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين فلا اقسم بمواقع
النجوم
وانتظم انه
لقران كريم في كتاب
مكنون لا يمسه الا
المطهرون تنز
من رب
العالمين افبهذا الحديث انتم
مدهنون وتجعلون رزقكم انكم
تكذبون فلولا اذا بلغت
الحلقوم وانتم حينئذ
تنظرون نحن اقرب اليه منكم ولكن لا
تبصرون فلولا ان كنتم غير
مدينين ترجعونها ان كنتم
صادقين فاما ان كان من
المقربين فروح
وريحان وجنه نعيم
واما ان كان من اصحاب اليمين فسلام لك من
اصحاب اليمين
واما ان كان من المكذبين
الضالين فن من حميم وتسيه جحيم ان هذا لهو
حق اليقين فسبح باسم ربك
العظيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين سبح لله ما في السماوات والارض وهو
على كل شيء
قدير وهو العزيز
الحكيم هو الذي يحيي و
له ملك السماوات والارض يحيي ويميت وهو
على كل شيء قدير هو الاول والاخر والظاهر
والباطن وهو بكل شيء عليم هو الذي خلق
السماوات والارض في سته
ايام ثم استوى على العرش يعلم ما ما يلج
في الارض وما يخرج منها وما ينزل من
السماء وما يعرج
فيها وهو معكم اينما كنتم والله بما
تعملون بصير له ملك السماوات والارض والى
الله ترجع
الامور يولج الليل في النهار ويولج النهار
في
الليل يولج الليل في النهار ويوج النهار
الليل وهو عليم بذات الصدور امنوا بالله
ورسوله وانفقوا مما جعلكم مستخلفين
فيه فالذين امنوا منكم
وانفقوا لهم اجر كبير وما لكم لا تؤمنون
بالله والرسول يدع م لتؤمنوا بربكم وقد
اخذ ميثاقكم ان كنتم
مؤمنين الذي ينزل على
عبده بينات ليخرجكم من الظلمات الى
النور وان الله بكم
لرؤوف وما لكم الا تنفقوا في سبيل الله
ولله ميراث السماوات
والارض لا يستوي منكم من انفق من قبل
الفتح وقاتل
اولئك اعظم درجه من الذين انفقوا من بعد
وقاتلوا وكلا وعد الله الحسنى والله بما
تعملون
خبير من الذي يقرض الله قرضا حسنا فيضاعفه
له
و كريم يوم ترى
المؤمنين يسعى نورهم بين ايديهم وبايمانهم
بشراكم اليوم جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار
خين فيها ذلك هو الفوز العظيم يوم يقول
المنافقون
والمنافقات للذين امنوا انظرنا نقتبس
منكم قيل ارجعوا
وراءكم فالتمسوا نورا فضرب بينهم بسور
له باطنه فيه الرحمه وظاهره من قبله
العذاب
ينادونهم الم نكن معكم
قالوا بلى
ولكنكم فتنتم انفسكم وتربصتم وارتبتم
وغرتكم
الاماني غرتكم الاماني حتى
جاء امر الله وغركم بالله
الغرور فاليوم لا يؤخذ منكم فديه ولا من
الذين كفروا ماواك النار هي مولاكم وبئس
المص الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحم
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم يان
للذين ان تخشع قلوبهم لذكر الله وما نزل
من الحق ولا يكونوا كالذين اوتوا الكتاب
من قبل فطال عليهم الامد فقست
قلوبهم وكثير منهم
فاسقون اعلموا ان الله يحيي الارض بعد
موتها قد
بينا لكم الايات لعلكم
تعقلون ان
المصدقين الله قرضا حسنا يضاعف لهم
ولهم
كريم الذين امنوا بالله ورسله
اولئك هم
الصديقون
شهداء عند ربهم لهم اجرهم
ونورهم والذين كفروا وكذبوا
باياتنا
اولئك اصحاب
الجحيم اعلم انما الحياه الدنيا لعب ولهو
وزينه
وتفاخر بينكم
وتكاثر وتكاثر
في الاموال والاولاد كمثل غيث اعجب الكفار
نباته ثم يهيج فتراه
مصفرا ثم يكون
حطاما وفي الاخره عذاب شديد
ومغفره من الله
ورضوان وما الحياه الدنيا الا متاع الغرور
سابقوا الى مغفره من ربكم
وجنه عرضها كعرض
السماء والارض اعدت للذين امنوا بالله
ورسله ذلك فضل الله يؤتيه من
يشاء والله فضل
العظيم ما اصاب من من
مصيبه في الارض ولا في
انفسكم الا في كتاب من قبل ان
نبراها ان ذلك على الله
يسير لكي لا تاسوا على ما فاتكم ولا
تفرحوا بما اتاكم والله لا يحب كل
مختال
فخور الذين يبخلون ويامرون
الناس بالخل ومن يتول فان الله هو الغني
الحميد لقد
ارسلنا
بالبينات
واننا معهم الكتاب
والميزان ليقوم الناس
بالقسط
وانزلنا الحديث
فيه باس شديد وما
للناس وليعلم الله من
ينصره ورسله
بالغيب ان الله قوي عزيز ولقد ارسلنا
نوحا وجعلنا في
ذريتهم النبوه
والكتاب فمنهم مهتد وكثير منهم
فاسقون ثم
ق اثارهم
برسلنا وقفينا بعيسى ابن مريم اتيناه
الانجيل وجعلنا في قلوب الذين اتبعوه رافه
ورحمه
ورهبانيه ابتدع
و
ابتدع ما كتبناها عليهم الا
ابتغاء رضوان الله
فوها حق
رعاها فاتينا الذين امنوا منهم اجرهم
وكثير
منهم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وامنوا برسوله يؤتكم كفلين من
رحمته يؤتكم كفلين من رحمته ويجعل لكم
نورا به ويغفر لكم والله غفور
رحيم لالا يعلم اهل الكتاب الا يقدرون على
شيء
من فضل
الله وان الفضل بيد الله يؤتيه من
يشاء
و الفضل
عظيم الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن ح
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله صلاه
الش الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اقرا بسم رب الذي
خلق
الانسان من علق اقرا وربك الاكرم الذي علم
بالقلم علم الانس
ما لم يعلم كلا ان
الانسان
ليطغى ان راه
استغنى
ان الى ربك
رجعا
الله الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين انا
انزلناه القدر وما ادراك ما ليله القدر
ليله
القدر من الف شهر تنزل
الملائكه والروح فيها باذن
ربهم من كل امر سلام هي حتى مطلع
الفجر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين ادنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اللهم احسن عاقبتنا في
الامور كلها
اجرنا من خزي و عذاب الاخره اللهم اقسم
لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا وبين
معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك ومن
القين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا وابصارنا وقوتنا ما
احييتنا واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا
على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا
الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا ملغ علمنا ولا الى
النار مصيرنا ولا تسلط علينا من لا يخافك
ولا
يرحمنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو عنا اللهم
انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا اللهم انا
نسالك العفو والعافيه في الدنيا والاخره
اللهم اغفر لنا ولابائنا
وهات ولاصحاب الحقوق علينا واغفر للمؤمنين
والمؤمنات والمسلمين والمسلمات احياء
وامواتا ربنا لا تجعلنا فتنه للقوم
الظالمين ونجنا برحمتك من القوم
الكافرين اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر واكتب
لنا ثوابها واجعلنا من عتقائك من النار
ومن
المقبولين اللهم اشف امراضنا اللهم اشف
امراضنا وبارك في اعمارنا وخذ
بنواصينا اليك ووفقنا ل خير الدنيا
والاخره من بما يرضيك وبما ترضى به عنا يا
كريم اللهم من على اخواننا المستضعفين في
غزه وفي غيرها بالنصر والتمكين اللهم كن
لهم عونا ونصيرا اللهم كن لهم عونا ونصيرا
اللهم اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من خوف اللهم
امنهم من خوف اللهم انتقم من عدوك وعدوهم
يا رب العالمين اقتلهم بددا واحصهم عددا
ولا تذر منهم احدا انهم يا رب لا يعجزونك
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر